nos dicen que fx es igual a la serie
infinita de n
1 hasta infinito de n 1 entre 4 a la n 1
por x a la n iv queremos encontrar la
integral definida de 0 a 1 de fx con
respecto a x y como siempre si se
sienten inspirados y los invito a que se
inspiren pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta o en
cualquier momento pueden pausar el vídeo
y tratar de resolver esa parte por su
cuenta vamos a reescribir esto esto es
igual a la integral definida de 0 a 1 de
esto y fx es todo esto esta serie así
que escribo la suma desde n igual a 1
hasta infinito de n 1 entre 4 a la n 1
por x a la n iv lo que voy a hacer a
continuación quizá alguno de ustedes les
parezca algo nuevo pero esto es
esencialmente la integral definida de
una suma de términos que es lo mismo que
la suma de varias integrales definidas
digamos que tengo esta integral definida
de 0 a 1 de g x + hdx más otros términos
con respecto a x pues esto es lo mismo
que tener la integral de 0 a 1 deje de x
con respecto a x más la integral de 0 a
1 de hd x con respecto a x etcétera es
igual a la suma de las integrales de
todos los términos individuales
esto viene directamente de las
propiedades de las integrales así que
vamos a aplicar esto mismo acá aunque
aquí lo haremos con la anotación sigma
esto va a ser igual a la suma desde que
n es igual a 1 hasta infinito de la
integral definida de 0 a 1 de cada uno
de estos términos lo escribimos la
integral definida de 0 a 1 de n 1 entre
4 a la n 1 por x a la n con respecto a x
ahora tendremos la suma de cada una de
las integrales de estos términos así que
vamos a ver
esto de aquí esto es igual esto es igual
a la suma desde que en es igual a 1
hasta infinito vamos a ver tomamos la
anti derivada de esto tendremos este
término original n 1 entre 4 a la n 1 ya
que aquí no tenemos nada de equis y para
nuestra integral es una constante y aquí
queremos incrementar el exponente y
dividirlo entre este exponente con
incremento es invertir la regla de la
potencia así que tenemos x a la n 1
entre n 1 solamente tomamos la anti
derivada de esto y vamos a ir de 0 a 1
para cada uno de estos términos y antes
de hacer esto vamos a simplificar lo
obtenemos en el 1 aquí entre n + 1 acá
que se cancelan y reescribimos esto como
la suma desde que en es igual a 1 hasta
infinito y aquí cuando x es igual a 1
tendremos uno a la n 1 entre 4 a la n 1
- 0 a la n 1 entre 4 a la n 1 podría
pensar a escribirlo pero esto es
claramente cero así que no lo escribo y
ahora no se está quedando algo bastante
bonito y simple esto va a ser igual a la
suma desde que n es igual a 1 hasta
infinito de un cuarto elevado a la n 1 y
pueden reconocer que esta es una serie
geométrica infinita cuál es el primer
término aquí
pues el primer término es cuando n es
igual a 1 esto va a ser un cuarto
elevado a la 1 más 1
igual a 2 14 al cuadrado que es lo mismo
que 1 entre 16 este es nuestro primer
término y nuestra proporción común va a
ser pues vamos a seguir multiplicando
esto por un cuarto así que nuestra
proporción común aquí es un cuarto así
que para una serie geométrica infinita
en donde nuestra proporción común o su
valor absoluto es menor a 1 sabemos que
esto va a converger y va a converger en
el valor 1 entre 16 dividido entre 1 -
la proporción común
1 - un cuarto aquí tenemos tres cuartos
así que esto es igual a 1 entre 16 por 4
tercios el 4 es 1 el 16 es 4 y nos queda
un doceavo y con esto terminamos al
principio parecía bastante complicado
pero simplemente dijimos bueno esto es
integral de una suma aunque sea una suma
infinita y esto será la suma de
integrales infinitas tomamos la anti
derivada de estas integrales infinitas
lo que pudimos hacer gracias a los
poderes de las matemáticas simbólicas y
nos dimos cuenta que teníamos una serie
geométrica infinita de la cual sabemos
cómo encontrar su suma y con esto
terminamos